Once shooting wraps on a movie, props usually
get packed up for the next film, auctioned
off for charity, or given to a museum.
But sometimes, actors just take the props
from the set for themselves, with no one the
wiser.
Whether for sentimental reasons or because
they feel their acting deserves a more tangible
reward than a paycheck, there are plenty of
famous actors who have admitted to nicking
some valuable, and not so valuable, props
once shooting was finished.
Here are some of the props that actors stole
from the sets of their movies.
Locket up
After the final film of the Hunger Games franchise,
Mockingjay: Part 2, was released, a few of
the main actors revealed that they had taken
some props home over the years.
Considering Josh Hutcherson played the perpetually
romantic Peeta, what he admitted to stealing
is actually quite sweet.
"I took home in Catching Fire the locket that
Peeta gives to Katniss that has the 3 pictures
in it, I took that one home."
Meanwhile, Jennifer Lawrence took home some
pieces of her character's amazing outfits.
"I have the leather jacket, the leather hunting
jacket."
"And my leather, um, hunting boots."
Unlike his co-stars, Liam Hemsworth claims
he didn't take part in any thievery.
So what did he leave the set with?
"Lots of memories and good friendships, that's
what I took."
Hammer home
While Liam might be surprisingly good-hearted
when it comes to not stealing things from
set, his brother certainly isn't as innocent.
Chris Hemsworth has kept a memento of every
single time he's been called upon to play
the God of Thunder in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
"Did you steal a hammer at least?
Did you take a hammer home?"
"A few, yeah."
"Oh, a few?
How many hammers do you have?"
"About five."
One of those hammers is on permanent display
in, well, his bathroom.
"It's next to the toilet, if you need some
assistance with that for whatever reason...:"
"So it's like a toilet paper holder, like
a very expensive…"
"It is now!"
Bella Swan, jewelry thief
Kristen Stewart was only 17 years old while
filming the first Twilight movie and 22 when
the final film, Breaking Dawn Part 2, was
released to theaters.
While her vampire love, Robert Pattinson,
and the rest of the cast reportedly don't
seem to have many fond memories of filming,
Stewart appears to have more of a soft spot
for the franchise.
She told People magazine that she kept some
jewelry that Bella Swan wears in the film
to better remember director Catherine Hardwicke
and co-star Robert Pattinson.
Stewart admitted,
"I kept the rings.
The rings are really important to me."
Unconventional desires
If there's any movie that depends on its props,
it would probably have to be 50 Shades of
Grey.
The franchise became a box-office smash and
made Dakota Johnson and Jamie Dornan almost
as wealthy and famous as the characters they
played.
But according to Marie Claire, Johnson took
something else home besides her massive paycheck,
one of the floggers from Christian Grey's
secret room.
She made sure to specify that it's just gathering
dust in her garage, which seems like a very
different use for the item than Christian
Grey would have for it.
Live long and pilfer
Simon Pegg has been pretty open about his
humble, nerdy beginnings, and at this point
he's definitely made it as a geeky lad living
out his dream jobs.
He appeared in 2009's Star Trek reboot and
reprised the role for the sequel, Star Trek:
Into Darkness.
According to Female First, Pegg finally accomplished
a long-time childhood goal by keeping a Starfleet
badge while filming the sequel.
"This is my Starfleet insignia."
Despite tight security, Pegg admitted that
he was able to slip the badge into his bag
without anyone noticing.
"It's kinda cool."
Secretly Slytherin
Daniel Radcliffe was only 11 years old when
he started filming Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone, and he continued to star in the franchise
for nearly ten years.
Considering he spent most of his childhood
providing childhood memories for other kids,
it makes sense that Radcliffe would want a
souvenir of his time spent on set, even if
he had to steal one.
That souvenir turned out to be a couple of
pairs of glasses that Harry Potter wears;
one from the first movie and one from The
Deathly Hallows Part 1.
It's a sweet reminder of the time he spent
on set, but you'd think he would've gone with
a wand, right?